[Music]
welcome back to the next episode of
what's up prof good day walter
good day my friend how are you doing i'm
going
very well and you this is not as hot as
last time
yeah no last time we had a sauna
that's right so it's a little bit cooler
today
the topic is still hot so
let me open with a word of prayer then
we can get into it
our heavenly father thank you so much
for bringing us again together
lord we need you more and more each day
please bless us with the in-working of
the holy spirit
and that we can have discernment we
ask this in the wonderful name of jesus
amen
sometimes i think that rome
is purposefully provocative
to see how far can they
push their agendas
without one word of remonstrance from
protestants
yeah and it always surprises me how
successful they are
correct no not no
body even mentions anything about what
we're going to discuss
no so we're going to talk a little bit
about
prayers for the dead because
it's not only prayers for the dead but
actually also prayers
to the dead after all if you can invoke
the help of saints then you are praying
to the saints
right so this was a major issue in the
reformation
but it seems to be dead
at the moment with no
no sign of a resurrection on the side of
protestantism
here's an article that appeared recently
on the
october the 23rd and
it's in crooks which is talking about
the catholic pulse and it says that the
vatican extends time to obtain
full indulgences for souls in purgatory
so that same old issue that arose
in the reformation is purposefully
being dangled before
the eyes and noses of the world
just to rub it in that rome has not
changed
exactly that's how i feel about it
i mean martin luther was very clear
right yeah and
that's the one of the main reasons he
wrote his 95 thesis
absolutely so let's just look at this
article
rome plenary or full indulgences
traditionally obtained during the first
week of november
for the souls of the faithful in
purgatory can now be gained throughout
the entire
month of november isn't that nice now
it always amazes me that they have these
times
when you can get a full indulgence
in november now if it was
in your power to relieve
the suffering of individuals
wouldn't you want to do it in january
february march april may june july
august september october november every
day on a daily basis exactly
no but we'll do it in november and let
those guys suffer for the rest of the
year right
this makes no sense to me whatsoever but
nevertheless
you can now gain it for the whole of
november also those who are ill
or home bound and would not be able to
physically visit a church or a cemetery
in the prescribed time frame still will
be able to receive a plenary indulgence
when meeting certain conditions
the apostolic penitentiary a vatican
tribunal that deals with matters of
conscience
said in a notice released october
23. then they have this picture of
women who are preying on all
souls day at a cemetery so
you can get an indulgence if you go to a
cemetery
that's fascinating yes
the tribunal also asked that priests be
particularly generous
throughout november in offering the
sacrament of reconciliation
in administering communion to those who
are
infirm the new provisions were made
after a number of bishops asked for
guidance as to how the faithful could
perform the works required for receiving
a preliminary indulgence
given the ongoing pandemic and
restrictions in many parts of the world
limiting the number of people who can
gather in any one place
this is interesting that the roman
catholic church
continues with its activity continues
with its mass
and all of these issues but
in protestant nations it is forbidden in
many countries
to have communion services
amazing it's amazing no baptisms no
you're allowed to sit at the restaurant
and eat
but you can't partake of a communion
service
traditionally the faithful could receive
a full indulgence
each day from november 1 to november 8
when they visited the cemetery
to pray for the departed and fulfilled
other conditions in particularly when
they went to a
church or an oratory to pray
november to all souls day
bishops conference in countries where
large numbers of faithful traditionally
go to confession
attend mass and visit cemeteries during
the week had asked how the faithful
could be accommodated given covet 19
restrictions
or in the case that a member of the
faithful was ill
in isolation or in quarantine
the cardinal said so the vatican decided
to extend the time one can receive a
full indulgence to include the whole
month of november
typically only a partial indulgent is
granted
after the first week of november
that's even more interesting so one week
and after that you can get a personal
indulgence but
unfortunately your loved one who is in
purgatory
has to suffer a little longer because
you missed it's just not going to happen
right
that doesn't make sense oh no
isn't this dangling something
in front of protestants who believe
the scriptures and understand what it's
all about
can you imagine if god was like this
with your salvation
ah you're you're
just a little bit too late sorry sorry
yeah
if you thought about it a week earlier
the european okay
it would have been okay yeah those who
cannot leave their homes or residents
for
serious reasons which included
government restrictions during a
pandemic he said
also can receive a plenary indulgence of
the reciting specific prayers
for the deceased or reflecting on a
gospel reading
designated for masses of the dead before
an image of jesus
or the blessed virgin mary or by
performing
a work of mercy now our young friend how
much of that is biblical
none none of it no are you sure
in actual fact to pray for
an idol is against the commandments
it's in front of an idol yeah it's it's
forbidden in the scriptures
and here's a works related thing
so this is amazing in all cases
one also must fulfill the normal
requirements set by the church for all
the plenary indulgences
which demonstrate a resolve to turn away
from sin
and convert to god so what are those
conditions they include having a spirit
detached from sin
going to confession as soon as possible
receiving the eucharist as soon as
possible
praying for the pope's intentions and
being united spiritually with all
the faithful
those are church rules and nowhere
do i read anything like that in the
bible you don't go to confession as soon
as possible
in the bible when you have sinned you
confess your sins to god and to god
alone who can forgive sins but god alone
says the bible
and they also said that the office
strongly
urged all priests to celebrate mass
three times
on all souls day as allowed for in a
document by pope benedict the 15th
the hope is that the availability of
more masses that day
would help everyone wanting to attend
mass to do so
while respecting capacity limits in
churches and places of worship
the church teaches that prayer
particularly the mass
and sacrifices may be offered on behalf
of the souls in purgatory the feast of
all
souls differs from the november 1 feast
of all saints precisely because it
offers
prayer for the eternal peace
and heavenly rest of all those who died
in a state of grace
but not totally purified
that's the bulk of humanity according to
them
so the catechism of the catholic church
says all who die
in god's grace and friendship
but still imperfectly purified are
indeed assured of the eternal salvation
but after death they undergo
purification
so as to achieve the holiness necessary
to enter the joy
of heaven a total
negation of justification
by faith exactly so
this is dangled in front of
the protestant world that sits with this
church in economical council
and for the sake of that wonderful word
called
solidarity goes along with any
compromise
whatsoever and thereby crucifying christ
afresh yes now this is a serious issue
and it is an issue that affects the
entire
world and in particular the christian
world
because this is not the first time this
has come up it was
a big issue in the time of christ
and it is a big issue in
many religions in the world thus praying
to the dead praying for the dead
ancestor worship all of these issues
are involved here now let's just get a
catholic definition
just to make sure this is catholic
answers
and the article is salvific
offerings for the dead now
what does salvific mean
for salvation absolutely
so now you can bring an offering for
offering for the salvation of the dead
i thought the bible said it is given for
man
once to die thereafter the judgment yes
but here you can do something for the
souls after they are dead right
so if they didn't live the
up to the standard of the bible now you
can do
offerings and pray for them that they
can be saved
without them having to acknowledge it
themselves
some religions go so far as to say you
can baptize the dead
well but let's not go there
offerings for the dead as faithful
catholics we are taught that we should
offer
prayers and reparations for the dead
how can you do a reparation for
something that someone has done who is
already dead
is that possible no if there's going to
be a reparation it has to happen before
you're dead right
when you have a decision to make this is
a spiritual work of mercy a
meritorious act on our part
it is in fact a foolish act
because once you are dead it's too late
to do any reparation the reparation
should come
before you die what does the bible say
about prayers for the dead
well we have some interesting verses
here
and i've used the esv
translation as well because it
translates
some words as necromancers which others
don't necessarily translate that way
deuteronomy 18 verse 9 when thou art
come into the land which the lord thy
god giveth thee thou shalt not learn to
do
after the abominations of those nations
they shall not be found amongst you
anyone that maketh his son or his
daughter to pass through the fire
or that uses divine nation or an
observer of times or an enchanter or a
witch
or a charmer or a consultor with
familiar spirits or a wizard
or a necromancer
that's someone who consults the dead
yeah it is
strictly forbidden in the word of god
leviticus 19 verse 31 says in the king
james
regard not them that have familiar
spirits
niagara seek after wizards to be defiled
by them i am the lord your god
now the esv translates that verse
do not turn to mediums or necromancers
that's people that consult the dead yeah
do not seek them out and so make
yourselves unclean by them i am the lord
your god
why would you be unclean when you
consult
the dead because the bible is pretty
clear that the dead no
nothing so who are you actually
consulting when you are consulting the
dead
demons you are talking to demons
masquerading
as loved ones yes here are a few more
verses
isaiah 8 19 in the
king james and in the esv and when they
shall say unto you
seek unto them that have familiar
spirits and unto wizards that peep
and that matter should not the people
seek unto their god for the living to
the dead
to the law and to the testimony if they
speak not according to this word it is
because there is no light
in them so the bible clearly says
that if you don't speak in harmony with
the word of god
the law is the torah the testimony is
what all the prophets
have written after that if you do not
speak in harmony with that there's no
light in them
the esv says quite plainly inquire
of the medians and the necromancers
who chip and mata
that's a a reference to
non-understandable utterings
very interesting leviticus
20 verse 6 in the esv if a person turns
to mediums and necromancers
whoring after them i will set my face
against that person and will cut him off
from amongst these people
that's pretty serious yeah in other
words when you
indulge in these things you are going
contrary to the will of god
because you are receiving instructions
from demons yeah leviticus 20 verse 27
a man or a woman who is a medium or a
necromancer shall surely be put to death
they shall be stoned with stones their
blood shall be upon them
now that was under the theocracy we
don't have a theocracy anymore so you
can't go and do that
but basically what god is saying is that
in the final analysis and the final
judgment that comes to
with the death penalty deuteronomy 14
verse 1 you are the children of the lord
your god
you shall not cut yourselves nor make
any boldness between your eyes
for the dead
now when you go to the religions
and you look up the word tanja it is the
practice of cutting or shaving
some or all of the hair on the scalp as
a sign of religious devotion or humility
actually no
it is a cutting for the dead
now if you go back to the old pagan
religions back to nimrod's time
then we learn that nimrod
of course was put to death and
it was accustomed to tonja yourself
to show that you are in solidarity let's
use that word
with this dead principle
so the term originates from the latin
word tonsura meaning clipping or
shearing and referred to a specific
practice in
medieval catholicism abandoned by papal
order in 1972.
now that is interesting
but we still find that clipping is a
very common practice in the world in
many religions
and nuns used to have their hair clipped
and shaven that's why they wore a
tabat and we find it also in other
religions
deuteronomy 26 verse 14 says
i have not eaten thereof in my morning
neither have i taken away oat thereof
for any unclean use
nor given ought thereof for the dead
but i have hearkened to the voice of the
lord my god and have done according to
all that thou
has commanded me in other words the
bible clearly says
we have nothing to do in terms of any
form of communication
with the dead that doesn't mean you
can't remember the dead
that cat doesn't mean you do not sorrow
for the dead
but there is no communication and there
is no change of status that is possible
yes
so here's a is a question that was
asked why do buddhists honor
our dead by feeding them if the dead
know nothing
then can you feed them no
catholic answers that article on
salvific prayers
if we continue to read what they
explained there
it says from the beginning the church
has honored the memory of the dead and
offered prayers
and suffrage for them
above all the eucharist sacrificed so
that
thus purified they may attain
the beatific vision of god the church
also
commends arms giving
indulgences and works of penance
undertaken on behalf of the dead
now all of these activities are
strictly forbidden in the word of god
so it's not only in non-christian
religions that we find this practice
but here in the heart of catholicism
we find it as well let us help and
commemorate them
can you help the dead no if job's sons
were purified by their father's
sacrifice
why would we doubt that our offerings
for the dead
bring them some consolation
let us not hesitate to help those who
have died
and to offer our prayers for them
well as i said before
now the world sits in an economical
council
and the protestant world assumes that
rome
is a christian institution
functioning according to biblical
principles
and then we have issues like this
document that has just been released
yeah and what are your thoughts my
thoughts is
that is important that you're saying
this because a lot of people will be
looking at this episode now and sitting
and saying okay but
we're not catholics so this doesn't
apply to us
but you're you are accepting catholic
principles in your life
that's what it's important to realize
like you said this economical agreements
with him now
does god work in harmony with error no
so the leading that we find
and the example that we find from this
system
which is being incorporated in the
legislation of the entire
world does it emanate
from a pure stream or does it emanate
from
a defined stream yes
that is the question we have to ask
ourselves
now when the reformation
was celebrated the 500th year of the
reformation they brought out all kinds
of documents and this was one of them
the declaration on the way church
ministry and the eucharist
and it was the question of unity between
brethren
of different denominations and
one of the issues that was mentioned in
this document
on page 36 the u.s dialogue around
this document the hope of eternal life
asserts the following
the fellowship of those sanctified the
holy ones or saints
includes believers both living
and dead now this is a document of
unification of the protestant world with
the catholic
world there is a solidarity of the
church
i'm very allergic to that word
solidarity it is being branded
everywhere today and there are quotes
available
on the web of pope francis using this
word
but it is popping up on a regular basis
in protestant documents yes solidarity
does that mean that you can have
solidarity in
blatant error
no in blatant apostasy against god's
word
and rebellion against his word so so you
have to compromise the whole time
you have to and in the previous episode
didn't we
see how you can obtain common good
is via compromise what was the downfall
of israel a compromise uh
yeah it was called syncretism yeah
mixing
pagan worship with true worship
in other words worshipping baal
in the name of jehovah exactly so
it's amazing that this document says
that the fellowship
includes the living and the dead so you
are actually celebrating the eucharist
together with the dead
there is thus a solidarity of the church
throughout the world with the church
triumphant this solidarity across the
barrier of death
is particularly evident in the eucharist
which is
always celebrated in unity with the
hosts of heaven
so the dead partake
particularly in praise and adoration of
god at the lord's table
the apparent division mocked by death
melts away
so you have one big feast one big feast
of celebrating together with the dead
that is as pagan as it can
possibly be great now what is
spiritualism teach on this
issue well spiritualism has six basic
fundamental principles
and this comes from their own sources
they acknowledge the existence of a
supreme intelligence
doesn't have to be a personal god right
no
and of course the immortality of the
soul we are
in essence spirits all of whom are
created simple
and ignorant but owning the power to
gradually
perfect themselves which is impossible
according to the scripture your
perfection is
imputed or imparted from god yes
and there is nothing that you can do
because
all our righteousness is filthy rags
reincarnation is then possible if you
are
a living spirit after death
plurality of inhabited worlds the
different orbs of the universe
are the various abodes of the spirits
so that means you can communicate with
them right
communist communicability of the spirit
spirits are the
disincarnate human beings spirits can
communicate with our material world
through mediums
what did we just read in the bible no
necromancing no talking to them it's
forbidden
and then morale based on the gospel of
jesus
that is syncretism of the highest order
this should already bring warning lights
to people
thinking that after thinking that
okay but we're not thinking and exactly
like the catholics do
we don't pray to the dead but you still
believe that they are in heaven and that
you have talked after death
and how can you say that something that
is contrary to the gospel of jesus
christ is based on the gospel of jesus
christ
so when those three unclean spirits
come together out of the mouth of the
beast which is catholicism
out of the mouth of protestantism and
out of the mouth of the dragon
which is spiritism then you have
the final union that will bring about
the conflict between righteousness and
unrighteousness
and this is exactly where we are in the
stream of time correct
now if you are silent
on an issue then you actually
condone it the bible says if you warn
the wicked man
then you've done your duty if you don't
it's upon your head
and this is the case with protestantism
it is silent on this issue news
the doctrine of the immortality of the
soul
ezekiel 18 20 says the soul that sinneth
it shall die and
here you're talking about this word that
is translated
soul it shall die
because the whole of the human being
is the soul and man became
a living soul you have to have
the dust and the breath of god to
constitute
constitute a soul correct one can't
exist without the other
correct one timothy 1 17 says
now unto the king eternal immortal
invisible the only wise god
the honor and glory for ever and ever it
is
only the king eternal who is immortal
one timothy 6 14 to 16 says that thou
keep this commandment without spot
unrebukable until the appearing of our
lord jesus christ
which in his time he shall show who is
the blessed and only potentate the king
of kings
lord of lords who only has immortality
the only one who has immortality is god
and those two whom he grants it yes
dwelling in the light which no man can
approach unto
whom no man has seen nor can see to whom
be honor and power
everlasting it's pretty clear that the
bible teaches that god alone
is immortal and jesus said
in john 11 11 to 14 our friend
lazarus sleepeth
but i go that i may awake him out of his
sleep
and then the disciples said lord if he
he shall do well i appeared jesus spoke
of his death but they thought he had
spoken of rest in sleep then jesus said
unto them plainly lazarus
is dead now if you are
in christ then
you're not really dead but when you
cease to exist in your present state
then you are in a state of sleep yes
unconsciousness and how long will you
remain
in that state well job tells us
in 14 12 till the heavens be no more
and the bible tells us when christ comes
the heavens shall depart like a scroll
they shall not awake nor be raised
out of their sleep it's pretty clear
psalm 6 5 for in death there is no
remembrance of thee in the grave who
shall give thee thanks
the dead praise not the lord neither any
that go down into silence psalms 115
verse 17 didn't that catholic document
just say that when you hold the mass
that the dead praise god
yeah they partake with you and they are
there
now which one is right the catholic
document or the bible
well isn't that a choice that people
will have to make
so rust in peace is
what seems to be what the bible tears
now we've discussed this many times but
just to
make sure that we understand it in its
completeness
it was the devil who said you shall be
as gods and that you will be immortal
genesis 3 and the serpent said unto the
woman you
shall not surely die you shall be as
gods so the bible is very
very clear immortality is
conditional to obedience to god
now the catholic church knows this very
well
in the office of the catechism article 1
366 the church teaches
that every spiritual soul is immortal
it does not perish when it separates
from the body at death
it's very well thought yeah it's the
church that teaches
it not the bible does that church
know that the bible teaches something
else
that's the question
well here's the new catholic
encyclopedia and it says the soul in the
old testament
means not a part of man but the whole
man
do they know yes as a living being
similarly in the new testament it
signifies
human life the life of an individual
conscious object
recent exegetes have maintained that the
new testament does
not teach the immortality of the soul
in the hellenistic sense of survival of
an immortal principle
after death does the catholic church
know
what the bible teaches yes does it
teach contrary to the bible 100
100 and he makes no bones about it no
so can i sit in the next council
how do you have solidarity with that how
do you have solidarity
what we make a compromise what
compromise can you make
so now we put some things on the side
we're actually compromising the bible
so if it's either one or the other
then it can't be both
fascinating now how adamant are they
about it
pope leo the 10th in 1513 now remember
this is
just before the reformation right
he said we do condemn and reprobate all
who assert that the intelligent soul
is mortal this bull was
directed against the growing what they
called heresy of those who denied the
natural immortality of the soul
and about the conditional immortality of
man in other words
if you believe the bible
then you were condemned as reprobate
so they're very adamant about it their
doctrine
will stand and the bible one
will not well in his 1520
published defense of 41 of his
propositions
luther cited the pope's inner
immortality
declaration as quote
one of those monstrous opinions to be
found in the roman
dunghill of the cretels he had a way
with words
martin luther so he didn't agree with it
right no definitely not
now why not well archbishop francis
blackburn states that
luther espoused the doctrine of the
sleep of the soul
upon a scripture foundation
and then he made use of it as a
confutation of
purgatory and saint
and continued in that belief to the last
moment of his life
now the reformers had an example before
them
they call themselves lutherans
and they don't believe what luther
believed
in fact they left us out of their
catechism
we should learn to view our death said
martin luther
in the right light so that we need not
become alarmed on account of it as
unbelief does because in christ it is
indeed not death but a fine sweet
and brief sleep isn't that what jesus
said yes
which brings us release from this veil
of tears
from sin and from the fear and extremity
of
real death and from all the misfortunes
of this life
and we shall be secure and without care
rest sweetly and gently for a brief
moment
as on a sofa until the time when he
shall
awaken us together with all his dear
children to his eternal
glory and joy there was martin luther's
face
after all he translated the bible right
so he must have internalized those
verses and thought about them
to come to this conclusion
for since we call it a sleep we know
that we shall not remain in it
but again awaken and live and
that the time during which we sleep
shall seem no longer
than if we had just fallen asleep
hence we shall censor ourselves that we
were surprised or alarmed at such a
sleep in the hour of death
and suddenly come alive out of the grave
and from decomposition
and entirely well fresh with pure clear
glorified life
meet our lord and savior jesus christ in
the clouds
did he study his scriptures definitely
absolutely he translated them so he knew
what he was talking about
and then he says scripture everywhere
afford such consolation
which speaks of the death of saints as
if they fell asleep and were gathered to
their fathers
that is had overcome death through this
faith and comforting christ and awaited
the resurrection
together with the saints who preceded
them in death
now the resurrection
was it contentious in jesus day
yes very much so the sadducees and the
pharisees had very different views on
the resurrection yeah
and jesus plainly taught the
resurrection from the dead
he rebuked the sadducees
so a fascinating war which has been
ongoing from the beginning
now william tyndall was also one who
translated the bible
and paid the ultimate price for what he
did
and british bible translator came to the
defense of the revised teaching of
conditional
immortality this as well as other
teachings brought him in direct conflict
with the papal
champion thomas moore
strongly objected against tyndall and
luther who in words of
muah said all souls lie
and sleep till doom's day so the
catholic church says
this is not going to be accepted
in 1530 tyndall responded
vigorously saying speaking to thomas
moreno
and ye in putting them the departed
souls
in heaven hell and purgatory destroy the
arguments where with christ
and paul prove the resurrection
and again if the souls be in heaven tell
me
why they be not in as good case as the
angels be
and then what cause is there of a
resurrection
yeah makes no sense no
so today the adventists
believe in the death
soul sleep resurrection
so you sleep until doomsday
this is a biblical position it was
taught in the bible
it was taught by the founders of the
reformation
movement tyndall pressed his contention
even further
showing that the papal teaching on the
subject is in conflict with
paul he sarcastically says no paul
thou art unlearned you must go to
mastermore
and learn a new way we be not most
miserable though we rise not again for
our souls go to heaven as soon as we be
dead
and are there in great joy as christ
that is risen again and i
marvel that paul had not comforted the
thessalonians with that doctrine
if he had wasted if he had known it
that the souls of the dead should rise
again
if the souls be in heaven in as great
glory as the angels after your doctrine
show me what cause should there be of
the resurrection
pretty logical argument yes
so this is coming to the fore again at
in the time that we are living yes
and that the papacy should in this very
day
and in this very month that we are
recording this issue
bring this to the fore again and rub it
under the
noses of the protestants without
one word of remonstrance is astounding
it is it just shows you where we are in
the stream of time like you said
yes we are at the end
now i know that there are many that will
say oh
there they go again with this adventist
doc
[Music]
let me show you an article by
warren prestage and this is a baptist
who has studied this and written an
article on it
and i think we should just browse
through the article
just to make sure that it is not only
the adventists that believe like this
but everyone who
really studies the bible yes absolutely
here is the article and there is the
the webpage as quoted
and it's by warren prestige and warren
prestige has a number of degrees and
he's a
baptist pastor and he taught at
secondary schools and universities and
he
authored this article on the sleep
of death and he opens up
the argument with the sleep of death
according to the bible the dead
whether christian or non-christian good
or evil saved or lost
are neither suffering in hell nor
laboring in
purgatory nor rejoicing in heaven rather
they have
entirely ceased to function
this is now as i would
say an independent source yeah
without consciousness they await the
resurrection of the dead
at the return of christ that is jesus in
the glory
of god to use a common biblical metaphor
they sleep the sleep of death
and then he quotes psalms 13
3.
now what is the sleep of death in the
old testament
dying is frequently referred to as
laying down
in sleep and the dead are said to be
asleep
three different hebrew words are used to
this effect
the first one is
i probably don't pronounce that
correctly
but nevertheless and then he gives the
examples deuteronomy 31
1 kings 2 and he says
david slept with his ancestors and was
buried and then he says compare acts 13
36 and over 30 similar incidences
second yashen examples
job 3 verse 13 psalms 13
verse 3 and daniel the dead sleep in the
dust of the earth
and the third one is shenach
for instance job 14 12
the dead will not awake or be aroused
out of
their sleep
the sleep of death affects all humans
the same way
there the wicked cease from trouble and
there the weary are at rest
it is a perpetual sleep no dreaming
is hinted at rather the metaphor
signifies
utter inactivity unconsciousness
and in effect non-existence
that's what the bible teaches yes
according to you now we're not going to
read the whole article he quotes many
verses
and we've looked at some of them for now
i shall lie
that hebrew word over there
sleep in the earth and you god will seek
me
but i shall not be
it talks about the story of the witch of
endor as a problem verse
in this issue but then again god forbade
the speaking
to mediums and necromancers
and he never ever saw samuel
it is only the witch of endo that told
him that it was
samuel yes so we don't have to
be caught by that particular verse
he talks about the word show he said
what then
of this word shall which we have already
encountered a couple of times the hebrew
word
soul occurs some 65 times in the old
testament
with a reference to the place or state
of the dead
the new testament equivalent is hardest
and he uses as an example acts chapter 2
verse 24 to 28
although often misleadingly translated
as hell shall is never once
depicted in the old testament as a place
or state of suffering
in fact of the wicked it can be said in
peace they go
down to soul
the true import of the word is clearly
conveyed by
various equivalents given in the same
context
equivalence of the pit
in various verses destruction
in various verses silence in
other verses corruption in other verses
the grave
the dust death
and that is what is referred to never
a place
he says alice explains show
in the dust and is probably best
understood generically
as the grave
he talks about the verses of being
asleep in christ and there are many
that the bible mentions we're not going
to go through all of them
we want to get to the gist of the matter
and that is diverse christian traditions
so he gives a nice bible study
showing that the dead sleep
and then he talks about these diverse
christian traditions
and he makes this statement now this is
not an adventist right
it is scandalous that despite the clear
consistent teaching of both the hebrew
and the greek testament
christian tradition has displayed great
confusion
over the death state today
it is very widely recognized that this
has been due largely to the influence of
ancient greek ideas
now when we go to the book of revelation
the body
of the sea beast
is the leopard right and that stands for
greece
so the body the structure
of the roman thinking is greek
philosophy
natural law state of the dead
we can go through the entire list it's
based on greek philosophy
an influence already strong in some
pre-christian
jewish circles paul althouse explains
the original biblical concepts have been
replaced by
ideas from hellenistic greek gnostic
dualism the new testament idea of
resurrection which affects the total man
has to give way to the immortality of
the soul
the two are not compatible you cannot
have a resurrection of the dead
and immortality at the same time which
makes
resurrection irrelevant
so it had to give way to this doctrine
of the immortality of the soul
the last day also loses its significance
for souls have received all that is
decisively important
long before this if you die and you go
to heaven you've got your reward why
would you want to be resurrected
yes doesn't make any sense
eschatological
tension that is christian hope is no
longer directed to the day of jesus's
coming the difference between this
and the hope of the new testament is
very great
and then he quotes here during the
middle ages an elaborate
four-fold doctrine of the death state
was evolved in the western christian
church
and this schema is reflected in dante's
great poem the divine
comedy and became standard for
roman catholicism in other words you
have this inferno where you go to
dante's infirma and
this is the state of the christian world
he also writes that all the 16th century
protestant reformers rejected the
doctrine of purgatory
for three good reasons
it is not found anywhere in the bible
it is contrary to the fundamental
salvation by grace alone
obviously right you can do good works
for the dead
exactly it is open to terrible abuse
as when the medieval church claimed the
power to relieve the suffering
of those in purgatory and charged the
faithful money to do so
some added a fourth reason there is
no immortal human soul
now as we have just seen
was this only the medieval church no
it started already in jesus time and
what about the present pope
didn't he just lengthen the indulgence
period
hasn't changed nothing has changed
through the reformation a simplified
scheme emerged
according to common protestant view of
death
the souls of the lost go immediately
to punishment in hell while the souls to
be
saved go immediately to heaven
there to enjoy full conscious communion
with christ
so the protestants have just skipped the
purgatory bit
correct although this is widely assumed
today to be
the christian view it is neither the
roman catholic view
because they claim you go to purgatory
first right
as we have seen nor the view of the
orthodox church
nor has it been widely held by
christians at all
until comparatively recently
so when people say that the adventists
are always
contrary to everyone else here is
someone
who is studying the issue and coming to
the conclusion
that the only way to resolve this issue
is to stick to the scriptures correct
so it's not arrogance it's just
simply obeying the word
of god as a matter of fact he writes the
idea of the souls
immediately ascend to heaven at death is
of greek gnostic origin
not biblical or christian
in my opinion it is precisely this view
that the apostle paul is arguing against
in his great resurrection chapter 1
corinthians 15.
those he opposes there saw no need of a
resurrection
verse 12 precisely because they assumed
in line with their greek platonist
upbringing
that the soul is immortal and held that
saved souls go to heaven
immediately at death then he has this
interesting quote from
bruce winter we'll just read a portion
not surprisingly then this view was
also roundly opposed by prominent
second and third century christian
teachers
such as justin martyr so
even in the early centuries of
christianity there was this war raging
yes it has never stopped because the
devil had said
you will surely not die and his word
is going to be law in fact it
is catholic canon law
so justin mata irenaeus
to tillian found it irreconcilable with
the hope of the resurrection
as it is to this day for that matter
justin martin told trifo a jewish
opponent
now this is interesting listen to this
he told him that if he encountered any
christian
who dare to blaspheme god by asserting
that there is
no resurrection of the dead but that
their souls are taken up to heaven
at the very moment of their death do not
consider them to be real christians
that is a serious indictment
so what would that mean
for the protestant world of this day
we've got a problem according
to justin martyr you are not to consider
them real christians
because the real christian believes in
the second coming of christ
that trump will sound the dead in christ
will rise
those that are living in christ will be
translated in a moment in a twinkling of
the
eye and together with the resurrected
will meet the lord in the air and those
resurrected are not ones that were in
heaven
no and that comes back to the grave and
now then there is a record
no they are sleeping in the grave until
the resurrection
if you read the book of daniel he's
plainly told
you will rest you will sleep
and you will stand in your lot on
that day the second coming of christ
so this is what it means to be an
adventist
to believe in the second coming of
christ as the hope
for all humanity
and the hope lies in the resurrection
which will be granted by christ on
condition
of obedience that's
biblical doctrine now why are we doing
this again
because we receive so many questions
about this issue and it needs to be
stated quite
clearly that this is not just
an issue of seventh day adventists
against the rest of the world
this is a biblical issue yes and here is
a baptist
yes and he puts it very plainly and also
that we're doing this to make people
aware
that even though you might not 100
percent
think the same or believe the same as
this roman catholic system
portrays it if you are in ecumenism with
them
if you have solidarity with them then
you are
acknowledging that this is okay you are
willing to compromise
on something where there can be no
competence no compromise
did christ make a compromise with the
sadducees and said they can continue to
believe what they believed
no did paul compromise with them no no
he mentions martin luther and he says
he's on record to having flatly denied
that the soul is immortal
luther generally understands the
condition between
death and the resurrection as a deep and
dreamless sleep
without consciousness and feeling luther
therefore says
nothing about souls without their bodies
enjoying true life
and blessedness before the resurrection
they sleep in the peace of christ
so this study i found very interesting
he states here today quite a number of
christians
are attached to modified doctrines of
purgatory
as a means not merely of purifying those
already saved but also of bringing all
humanity
perhaps to eventual salvation
if you believe in the second chance
doctrine
then you basically believe in a form of
purgatory
yeah and also if you
like the part says their eventual um
salvation for all humanity because like
we've read
even if you're if you weren't living up
to what you should have and
you might be lost somebody can now pray
for you
on the other side well that's not
catholic doctrine exactly their
their doctrine states that if you die in
a state of grace
which means that you went to confession
or you received
absolution then you go to purgatory if
you die in a state of mortal sin
according to them you bypass purgatory
go straight to hell
okay so the indulgence that gets you
just out of purgatory just gets you out
of pocket
so you there where you burn off this
your sins yes
but you're still saved now it is not a
forgiveness of sins
it is a relinquishing of the penalty of
sin
but the bible tells us that christ bore
the penalty
in my behalf it is a negation
of the atonement of christ it is a
blatant
affront to the christian doctrine of
salvation
in christ and christ alone that's why
you can venerate saints
that's why you can violate all the
commandments of god
and get away with it because the very
basis of the christian doctrine has been
denied
so he states the idea of universal
salvation will be discussed in chapter 6
and 9 of this particular book as for
purgatory in any form
there is simply no biblical warrant
for such a doctrine we have no evidence
that jesus or the apostles
ever taught the doctrine even in a weak
seed form
there's nothing but nothing in the
scriptures
it is also noteworthy that as dr harris
correctly observed
resurrection and judgment are
inseparably
associated that's a very important point
resurrection and
judgment are linked and cannot be
separated
yet as you also concede it is hard to
find
any reference in the new testament to a
judgment of the individual at death
it's not only hard it's impossible
unless you want to say it is given for
man once to die
and thereafter the judgment but it
doesn't say that the judgment will take
place
at the death it says it will take place
right
correct of course this is also a further
reason to reject the whole idea of saved
or lost
souls going to heaven hell or purgatory
at death
biblically judgment occurs at the end of
the age
on god's appointed day not
before isn't this what adventists
believe
and here is a baptist confirming
that this is exactly what the bible
teaches
in contrast to the confusing diversity
of christian traditions
stands the clear and consistent teaching
of scripture
jesus second coming through which god's
kingdom is finally achieved
will be an event which intervenes in our
time
and our world to wind up judge and
transform our history
this is exactly what adventism
stands for that's why the name is
adventist
so when the son of man comes in glory
the nations will be gathered before
him and he will separate people from one
another as a shepherd
separates the sheep from the goats the
creation itself will be set free from
its bondage to decay and will obtain
the freedom of the glory of the children
of god this is
obvious from the mere fact that a
generation will be alive
on earth when it occurs and will
experience
rapture without dying now this is not a
secret rapture
as many teach this is the final
resurrection
and then he quotes the verses the
resurrection to immortality and
everlasting fellowship
with christ will occur only in and
through that event
through the second coming of christ so
this is what
a baptist pastor believes
so now that we've studied this whole
issue of
death we can understand that the
veneration of saints and of mary
is not biblical so
any apparition of that nature cannot be
marrying
because she's sleeping in a state of
unconsciousness
according to the scriptures right they
of course teach that she never died that
she went bodily to heaven
yeah but if you go to jerusalem you will
find various graves of mary so it's a
very confusing issue
now they've just issued a coin on
october 16
2020 the new vatican coin depicts
mother carrying the earth in her womb
but they also teach that mary is the ark
yes because she contained
jesus right which is the embodiment of
the law
which by the way they negate
so now they have mother earth as
an equivalent this is syncretism
of the highest order joining
paganism with christianity
something which the bible condemns
in no uncertain terms
so the new coin minted by the vatican
city state depicts a woman carrying the
earth in her
womb the artist who designed the coin
which commemorates earth day has said
the design
was his response to the ecological theme
he was commissioned to portray
so he's an italian sculptor and catholic
who designed the coin
and he told cna that's catholic news
agency
that he wanted to imagine the earth as a
young pregnant woman who protects the
earth
but they had a festival in rome as we've
discussed in a previous occasion
where they honored this earth mother
yeah the
amazon senate with had the pachamama
statues and everything
absolutely and the pachamama statue that
is actually the same as this because
it's a pregnant a pregnant lady so
whether they do it in the form of mary
or whether they do it
in this form is irrelevant the image in
the coin has been compared
to carved wooden figures of a pregnant
woman that were on display
in churches and at events during vatican
synod of bishops on the amazon those
figures referred to by pope francis and
others as
pachamama as you just said
were said by some to depict an andean
fertility goddess while the vatican
spokesman
characterized them more vaguely as
symbols
of life the whole point of this
discussion
is that the world is moving to a point
of decision either
we move along in this current
and as the children of israel they were
about to go
across into the promised land
mingled with the nations around them
and accepted the worship practices of
the nations
and led to this great demise we are on
that same road repeating
the history the same decision are you
going to go
with this or are you going to stand and
say no
absolutely so just to make absolutely
sure
he is the veneration of mary in the
catholic church
in the catholic church the veneration of
mary mother of jesus
encompasses various marian devotions
which include prayer
pious acts visual arts poetry
music devoted to the blessed virgin mary
popes have encouraged it while also
taking steps to reform
some manifestations of it
all of the latest popes have been
very fermented mariologists
in conclusion
the question at hand is
are we in the moment of decision
are we going to go along with the stream
and follow the dictates of rome
and accept that they are part of the
christian community
or are we going to come out
and be separate what is the biblical
directive
come out and be separate and touch not
the unclean
thing and i will receive you
so we are living in very very
troubleless times
and god will have to give us wisdom
we are going to discuss in the next one
the issue of solidarity yes
a word which is being used over and over
again by the papacy
and protestant publication yes
and in the light of what we have just
discussed
we want to ask the question is this kind
of solidarity
even possible given the directives of
scripture
may god give us wisdom amen let's pray
heavenly father the world
is so confused and the old battle lines
still exist to this very day
and the same confrontations which have
plagued the people of god through the
ages
are now again coming to the fore
and god's people will have to make a
decision
help us to make decisions which are in
harmony with your word
is my prayer in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you